اكثر من سبعين اليه عسكريه اقتحمت مدينه
جنين
تصدى مقاومون فلسطينيون لقوات الاحتلال
فاندلعت اشتباكات مسلحه
جنود الاحتلال استخدموا الذخيره الحيه
فقتلوا ادهم جبارين من قاده كتيبه جنين
وجواب بواقره وهو استاذ مدرسه
[موسيقى]
الجيش الاسرائيلي زعم ان الهدف من العمليه
اعتقال خالد ابو زينه احد ابرز قاده
الحركه الجهاد الاسلامي لم يعتقل خالد
اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال اثنين من ابنائه
العالم كله
حتى خلال سجن وانا موجود عند الاسرائيليين
انا اغلى وقت في العفوله وهذا هم بيعرفوه
هسه اذا هم عندهم بدهم اياه اني انا ما
طلعتش ازور اسير وما طلعش يزور همم
شهيد او اروح على بيت اجر هاي بايدي عنهم
وخلال الاتحاد اطلق الجنود الاسرائيليون
النار باتجاه مستشفى الشهيد خليل سليمان
ومنع الطلاقم الطبيه من اسعاف الشهيدين
ابن الشهيد جواد بواقنه تحدث عن ظروف
استشهاد والده وهو يحاول انقاذ احد الجرحى
فتحت الباب انا وابوي
كان طخوا رصاصه من هون طلعت
الاضراب العام شل الحياه في جنين غضبا
وحدادا على ارواح الشهداء اما حملات
الاعتقال فلا تتوقف فقد اعتقلت قوات
الاحتلال اكثر من 10 فلسطينيين خلال
الساعات الاولى من يوم الخميس ليصل عدد
المعتقلين الفلسطينيين الى المئات منذ
بدايه العام الحالي نفذت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي 9 عمليات عسكريه منذ بدايه
العام الجاري معظمها في جنين تخللها قتل
وجرح واعتقال ويتوقع كثيرا من الفلسطينيين
ان تستمر هذه السياسه في ظل حكومه توصف
بانها الاكثر التطرفا في تاريخ اسرائيل
يشوفوا المديريه الجزيره من امام سجن عوفر
العسكري غربي رام الله